- Wait for a minute.
I was like, "Is he coming
out with a cape on?"
- No, there was like a curtain there
and I didn't know the
door was gonna slide.
So I'm like, "I'll open the curtain."
And then it like whatever.
- I thought it looked
like you were just gonna
have a cape and a reveal.
- I could do that.
- [Kelly] I know.
- Yeah.
- But it's been a couple years.
So I heard that you have a grandson now.
- I had my first grandchild.
(audience cheers)
- [Kelly] That's exciting.
It's way more fun with grandkids, right?
- [Jeff] Oh my God.
I had no idea I had this much
untapped love inside of me.
- [Kelly] Look at that thing!
- [Jeff] And the cool
thing was my daughter
got on "Jerry Springer"
and we were able to find
out who the father is
without spending one
dime of our own money.
- Yeah. So that was-
- [Kelly] Cleared it right out.
Wait, so is he gonna call
you something southern
like papa or anything?
- All right.
So years ago when I was doing
"Are You Smarter than a 5th Grader?",
I wrote three children's books
and a friend of mine,
his little girl,
couldn't say my name.
And so she would always go,
"Dad, let's read the Jex Foxworley book."
And so when my kids heard that
they never called me dad again,
they just call me Jex.
Jex.
And I thought, "Well,
little kids can say it,
that'll be my granddad name.
I'll just be Jex."
Well, and my wife was gaga.
And then,
so my son-in-law's mom forgot our names
like a couple months in
and she said, "So how is
Gaga and Chex Mix doing?"
(audience chuckles)
And so now my kids heard that
and that's all they call,
they call me Chex Mix.
So I'm gonna be the only
granddad in the world,
it's like, "Who would go?"
(Kelly laughs)
Should I be Pringles?
- [Kelly] Muddy Buddies?
- Yeah, I mean, no.
I'll be Chex Mix.
- I like Chex Mix.
- [Jeff] So That's my grandad-
- So they call you Chex Mix?
- Yeah, when I walk in
and then they have my grandson,
they're like, (yells) "Chex Mix!"
(Kelly imitates trumpet blowing)
- Yeah.
- I love it.
(both chuckle)
So this is what I find amazing
'cause you're hilarious
and you're such a sweet guy,
but I did not know that
you were such an artist
and you you drew a picture
for your grandson's nursery
and I have to show everybody
'cause I was blown away.
That's like, wait, what?
(audience gasps)
Like, people don't know
how to draw like this.
- Well, my daughter had an elephant
that was like brown and black.
And she said, "I wish I had a baby zebra
but I don't want black stripes,
I want brown."
And I said, "I'll draw you one."
And so I drew that.
- I mean, have you always been able to,
obviously, you've been an
artist since a young age like-
- I've always drawn.
I never had lessons or anything.
I painted him a rabbit too-
- [Kelly] What?
- so yeah.
- What? That's amazing!
- I have stacks of books.
I draw people in airports
and then put funny captions on 'em.
And so that's like something
nobody knows about me but-
- [Kelly] You should make a book!
- But when my friends come over,
they don't even want to talk about any,
they go, "Go get the books.
Go get the books."
- That's what I'm saying.
You should do that,
especially if they're
inappropriate things.
- [Jeff] They are
inappropriate. (chuckles)
(Kelly laughs)
- [Kelly] Be a great book.
- Yeah, it would.
- I'd buy it.
Wait, that was a look at
his new Netflix special,
"Jeff Foxworthy: The Good Old Days".
So this new special,
it's been 24 years since you've
done a special like that?
- Since I did one by myself.
So I did like three or four
in the beginning of my career.
And then I did three blue collar
- Yeah.
- ones with the other guys
and then Bill Engval
and Larry the Cable Guy and I did one
and then I did one with Larry
and then somebody said,
"You know, you haven't done
by yourself in 20 years."
And I'm like, "All right."
And and here's the crazy
thing about comedy.
It's like singers.
If you have five hits,
you play to your 90.
I mean, people come to hear those hits.
- What. Amen.
- Comedy's the opposite.
- Yeah.
- Once you've done it,
it's an album or a special
you have to throw that away
and start from scratch again.
- [Kelly] New material.
- So it's a challenge to do it.
- I love though this speak
of like the encyclopedias
'cause it's also like that
understanding is the same.
I grew up with like Layaway.
Did you grow up with Layaway?
- Oh, Layaway.
- [Kelly] It's the same thing.
- Did you grow up with green stamp books
where you would save-
- [Kelly] Yes, we did.
- the green stamps from the grocery store.
- Yes we did.
And you'd put 'em all on the,
and you'd collected the, yes, yes.
- Which is how this started
'cause my father-in-law walks around
with his pants up to his nipples.
(audience laughs)
(Kelly laughs)
He got his chest hair
caught in his zipper.
How do you do that?
So, but he always talks about
how much better things were
in the good old days.
And so when COVID hit,
I said, "I'm gonna do
a deep dive on this."
So I went "All right.
What were beds like when I grow,
how are beds now?
What was school like?
How's school now."
And so it's a real fun special
because it's like multi-generational.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Jeff] It's like young
people on (indistinct)
and you're just like
doing a ping pong match
and some of it was better then,
and some's better now.
- I was gonna say, "Yeah, I don't know."
But I don't know.
Some things would be cooler back then.
- Like, I'll tell you.
Remember when you were a kid
and you would go to the doctor's office
and if you behaved you got to pick a toy
out of the treasure chest?
- No, I didn't have that doctor.
- You didn't have the treasure chest?
How many people had the treasure chest?
(audience cheers)
- No, I just gotta be real with you.
You had to be like dying.
We were that kind of poor.
(Jeff laughs)
You had to be like almost
dead to go to the doctor.
Doctors were for rich people.
- [Jeff] No.
It was always a cheap toy,
but if you behave-
- That's exciting.
- Yeah.
- And I'm like, "Why did that stop?"
I mean, I wouldn't mind
going to get a physical now
and have the doctor
put on the rubber glove
to check my prostate
if I knew on the way out
I could stop by the treasure chest
and get a spider ring, you know?
(audience claps)
- A ring pop?
- [Jeff] Yeah.
(Kelly chuckles)
I love (chuckles),
no, my kids always get a sucker.
I'm like, "I should get the sucker.
I've been pinning them
down gettin' the shot."
(Jeff laughs)
So have their been any jokes
that drove your wife crazy?
'Cause like as a songwriter
I use people sometimes
in my life in songs.
So you obviously do
that with your material.
- Well, I have always
talked about my family,
but in the beginning of my career,
I used to do a thing.
When I first got married,
all these things that I
didn't understand about women
and one of the jokes was
is I don't know why when
a woman gets in the bed,
the temperature of her feet
and butt drop to below freezing.
(indistinct) it could be 98
but that butt is ice cold, you know.
- This is true.
- It's snuggling with a
Butterball turkey, you know?
And so-
- And that can be
a different size of Butterball
whoever it (laughs).
- But like that was 30 years
and people still come up
to my wife in the airport
and they go, "Are you the
one with the cold butt?"
And she's like, "Stop
talking about my butt!"
- [Kelly] But you know what?
That's true.
I don't know what is that?
Circulation? My feet always
get cold and my butt.
- Yeah.
And my wife will go,
"Let me put my feet on on you."
And it's-
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- they should use that instead
of the shock paddles to restart a heart.
- I don't know what happens.
I have no circulation.
I don't get it.
But before you got into comedy,
you worked at IBM-
- Yeah.
- which I find,
I can't see you working in a cubicle.
- No.
Well, it sounds more glamorous.
I carried a tool bag.
I fixed machines,
but I had to wear a suit and tie
and it was a good job.
- What a manly thing.
You fixed machines.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] Okay. Okay.
- But I was the guy
that was always in the break room
doing impersonations of the boss
and then you'd turn around,
the boss would be in
the doorway, you know?
- Yes.
(audience chuckles)
- And a bunch of people I worked with
used to go to the local comedy club
and they kept going,
"You're funnier than those people."
And they entered me in a contest,
not an amateur night,
a contest for working comics.
And I'm like, "Oh crap!"
So I went home and I wrote
five minutes about my family.
I'd never been on stage.
And I went down
and I won the contest.
- What?
(audience cheers)
That's how you got started?
That's when you know
you're supposed to do it.
- I knew a minute and a half into it.
I'm like, "This is what I want to do.
I love this."
- It has to feel magical to get up there
and make people laugh.
- [Jeff] I met my wife that night.
She was an actress and she
had just done a TV thing
with a guy that was a comedian.
And so they went there to
root for him in the contest.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I beat him.
So I met my career and my
wife four minutes apart
right there.
- Wow.
(audience cheers)
I love that!
I love that you had that
fire right off the bat.
That's cool.
- Well, I quit my job at IBM
and my mother's first question,
"Are you on the dope?"
(audience laughs)
Whatever the dope,
what is the dope?
- And I said, "No."
I said, "I think I've got a gift for this.
I want to try it."
And I didn't think it would work,
but I wanted to try it.
- Yeah.
- Five years later,
I'm on "Johnny Carson".
The same mother said,
"You know, you wasted
all those years at IBM."
(Kelly chuckles)
(audience chuckles)
- Turned it around.
- Yeah, whatever.
- "I believed in him the whole time."
- Yeah. Right.
Right.
- [Kelly] It's that thing.
Wait, so you had Johnny
Carson sign a baseball, right?
So do you have a thing with baseballs?
- As a kid I loved baseballs
and I had a couple of baseballs
autographed by baseball players.
- I mean, that's normal.
- That's normal.
- Yeah.
- But then I started thinking
when I got into this job,
I thought, "Well, wouldn't
it be cool if I got",
so like I did Johnny and I was like,
"Mr. Carson, would you sign a baseball?"
And then if I was hosting Country
Music Awards or something,
I'd take baseballs.
And now I have like 500 baseball
and very few of 'em are baseball players.
Yeah.
- [Kelly] That is so cool.
- [Jeff] There's like Johnny Carson,
Bob Newhart, Richard Pryor.
- [Kelly] You got Bonnie Raitt.
Okay.
- [Jeff] Bonnie Ray.
- [Kelly] So wait, has
anyone ever been like, why,
like for instance,
a golf player or basketball player?
Are they like, "Why am
I signing this ball?"
- Yeah.
There's Tiger Woods.
He's like, "I'm a golfer."
And I said, "I know that.
I know that.
- [Kelly] I'm aware.
- I just get everybody on golf balls."
- I mean on baseballs.
So, yeah, I got like five presidents.
I threw out the first pitch
for the brace one night
and Jimmy Carter was in the stands
and I'm like, "Hey, well you?"
That's the ball I threw out.
- Okay. So you might think this is cool.
I'm about to be cool to you maybe,
I only have one baseball
and I have it signed
and it's from Nolan Ryan.
- Oh, that's really cool.
(audience cheers)
- It's pretty cool.
- Yeah. Really cool.
- [Kelly] I'm a Texas girl.
- Yeah.
- So it meant like a
lot to me 'cause that's,
I didn't watch a lot of sport ball
but I did know Nolan Ryan
and I did watch Nolan Ryan.
- [Jeff] Yeah.
- I'm like, yeah.
So anyway, I thought that
that was pretty cool.
- You know the sad thing though
is I don't even have
a Kelly Clarkson ball.
- Okay.
Well, let me give you that one right now
'cause I was prepared.
- Yes!
- I was prepared.
(audience cheers)
I was like, "Whatever,
Bonnie Raitt and presidents
and I'm gonna lower the value
of your baseballs right now."
- No you're not.
No you're not.
Your ball is going right on
top of the Elton John ball,
I've kept a place right there.
- (chuckles) On top.
I'm gonna make sure he
knows that I'm on top.
- [Jeff] Yeah. (laughs)
- So many jokes. (wheezes)
- Okay. So once again I use Pilots.
I don't know if you know-
- So there is a sweet spot.
- Wait, where?
Where is the sweet spot?
- The sweet spot
- [Kelly] The sweet spot.
- [Jeff] is right there.
- [Kelly] Right there.
Okay.
- [Jeff] So when a bunch
of people sign a ball
the most prestigious ones
signs the sweet spot.
- Okay. Okay.
I'm gonna make sure no one runs
so I add mine properly.
- [Jeff] Yeah.
- Once again, I don't know
if you know this, Jeff
but I am using Pilot's
Permanent Premium 400:
the go to marker of "The
Kelly Clarkson Show".
I'm using it right now.
Here we go.
I don't wanna mess this up.
- [Jeff] It's a little bit hard
'cause its curved.
- But signing a ball,
yeah, it's curved.
Challenge accepted.
- And the ball players learned to do it
where the pen never leaves the surface.
- Oh well don't make me feel bad about it.
- [Jeff] No, I can't do it that way.
- This was pretty amazing.
- Oh
- You got a smiley face.
(Kelly chuckles)
- I'm so excited.
(audience cheers)